you
you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast real world tips for
managing a successful life science lab
redesigned presented by matt anderson
and brian garrett we're excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
lab con co serving the scientific
community since 1925 lab con co
manufactures laboratory equipment
specializing in ventilation products
such as chemical fume hoods and
biological safety cabinets other product
lines include glassware washers and
freeze dryers lab con co has ISO 9001
certification one measure of the
company's commitment to quality and
consistency and design and manufacturing
lab con co equipment is manufactured in
Kansas City Missouri and Fort Scott
Kansas and marketed worldwide to
academic industrial life science
pharmaceutical environmental forensic
and clinical laboratories to learn more
about lab con coke please visit
www.azpbs.org to sign up the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right and finally if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or you can use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce today's
speakers Matt Anderson is the biosafety
officer at university of
nebraska-lincoln in the department of
environmental health and safety
he has a doctorate in chemical biology
from Washington University in st. Louis
and completed a one-year postdoctoral
fellowship in biosafety at Washington
University in st. Louis Matt is a
registered biosafety professional
through Absa and he is active in Absa
international and Mavi on the Midwest
area biosafety Network masters as
co-chair of the AB site international a
communications committee and as
president of ma beyond he has
participated in numerous lab design
projects while at the University ranging
from new chemistry teaching labs to
biological research labs to a high
containment animal biosafety level three
lab brian garrett is the product manager
for biosafety cabinets and ductless fume
hoods at lab conquer corporation in 2010
he was accredited as a LEED Green
Associate with the US Green Building
Council before joining lab Congo he was
a laboratory director for the Institute
for environmental health laboratories in
Omaha Nebraska where he focused on
planning and management of two labs in
the beef industry analyzing foodborne
pathogens he is a member of the
controlled environment testing
Association and the American biological
Safety Association International and
sits on the Joint Committee for NSF ANSI
standard 49 please join me in welcoming
Matt Anderson I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you for
the introduction Judy before I begin I
wanted to state that the opinions and
perspectives that I'm just going to
share are my own and not a
representative of my employer but I do
want to share my experiences as a safety
officer and provide some tips for good
lab design that I have gained through my
experience
so what are the components of safe lab
design there are several key factors
that all have a role in making lab a lab
safe and I'll touch on each of these in
my part of the presentation today
these include design engineering
controls procedures personal protective
equipment or PPE and the people that
work in the labs on this slide you see
the hierarchy of controls that are used
to Alette to eliminate and minimize
hazards in the workplace these are also
good things to consider when designing
or renovating existing labs evaluating
if an existing space needs to be
maintained or if it can be eliminated if
you are in an older space don't be
content with replicating your existing
lab with new materials now is the chance
to rethink to improve and to design for
the future is there a better way to do
things is there better equipment out
there are there better processes now is
your chance to make a Chan change for
the better I know a lot of science that
scientists like to argue I've done it
this way for years why do I need a
change well the answer is that times are
changing people want to be safe feel
safe in their workplace and the public
is starting to demand safe labs so they
feel safe outside the labs and can be
assured that nothing is going to get out
and harm them the first question to ask
is can they go hazard buy be eliminated
do you have to work with that chemical
do you have to work with that material
if you don't then eliminate it from your
process the same can be said of the of
the design components if you if the
piece of the lab is is outdated if you
don't need it then eliminate it is there
a better solution out there you know
substitution is the next step if there's
a less hazardous chemical or a less
hazardous material for the material that
you're working with and the process
you're working with then you use that
instead so the hazard is reduced if you
can't eliminate or substitute the hazard
do you have appropriate engineering
controls in place are you working in a
fume hood is their proper exhaust in the
lab
if you have proper engineering controls
but they still haven't eliminated the
hazard the next step is to look at your
procedures and administrative controls
do you restrict access to the lab do you
require material being handled in a
certain way you require extensive
training to work with certain materials
those are examples of procedures and
administrative controls the final
consideration after all of those have
not have failed to minimize your risk to
assets obscure a acceptable level is to
look at the personal protective
equipment being used and institute PPE
so the workers can be protected from the
hazard so now that we've talked about
the steps that to take to eliminate
occupational hazards let's move on to
discussing the first factor in making
lab safe which is good lab design
designing a new lab or renovating an
existing one should be viewed as an
opportunity to fix the shortcomings of
existing or former spaces designed the
space to be adaptable to retain terrain
changes and research over time try not
to design the space for a specific type
of research sometimes this can result in
expensive renovations in the future if a
new occupant is has put in place the
infrastructure for the lab should be
able to handle in future needs
do you have sufficient engineering
controls containment equipment do you
have enough humanoids you have enough
biosafety cabinets you have the exhaust
capability to handle those kind of
pieces of equipment are your exhaust
needs appropriate that's technically an
engineering control but it has to be
thought of when you're doing the lab
design and it's an important
infrastructure piece is the lab need to
be negative to the hallway is there
directional airflow need to be in place
you have enough airflow through the lab
are there enough air changes to make
sure that not just odors and things like
that are exhausted out of the lab and
workers aren't exposed to those things
is the electrical load sufficient do you
have enough outlets you have emergency
power do are those power those
let's add power critical equipment in
good locations can you put the equipment
you want to put in there and in the
right places so it makes sense and it's
works well it's also important to hire
architects that have lab design
experience there are plenty of
architectural firms out there that will
bid on your project but they may not
have any experience designing a lab make
sure you have get one that has
experience building lab laboratory
spaces also make sure that you consult
with the lab workers the managers and
directors when you're doing the looking
at your lab design the frontline workers
need to have a voice in the design
they're the ones they're going to be
working in the lab every day they're the
ones that are going to have the best
perspective on what things can be fixed
what things they make them feel safer
and will allow them to work more
efficiently and finally the managers and
supervisors need to be involved in this
as well they need to make take ownership
of the programming in the design of the
space and they owe that to to the design
and to the workers so some of the
components of a good lab design that
I've seen implemented well and I've also
seen overlooked in lab design are shown
on this slide
and those include designated areas for
specialized research so if you have
microscopy spaces or if you are working
with radioactive materials or pathogens
infectious diseases or other other high
hazards it's good to have dedicated
spaces to those types of research it's
also good to have common equipment rims
for equipment that's shared
deep and then when you have freezer
farms if you have ultra low freezers
those put out a lot of heat it's
necessary to have augmenting cooling in
those spaces that's something that it's
important to consider it and at the
design phase you make sure that it gets
incorporated separate tissue culture and
pathogen labs are a good thing to have
as well to make sure that those things
you're working with and those spaces are
contained and not there's an erisa them
getting out or people that
don't work with those getting exposed to
those type of things also a bit as
important just as important as having
separate office and eating areas that
are outside of the lab spaces it's very
tempting for people to take their work
to their into the lab or to take food
into the lab if there are spaces for
them to do that in the lab have any
separate lunch rooms and then having
policies that lab lab at higher and
stuff like that doesn't go into those
lab those spaces is important to make
sure that everybody is safe in the
building and finally are to make sure
that your finishes are compatible with
the research materials you want surface
surfaces that are easily cleaned and
that are compatible with the various
chemicals or other processes you may be
working with so open lab design is a
topic I want to touch on and has been
very popular in in design of
laboratories in the last 10 or 15 years
the intent with this is to allow for
flexibility and to encourage
interdisciplinary and collaborative
research the downfall is that it is very
difficult to isolate the various hazards
that are present when you work in a lab
with an open design as an example let's
say you have four researchers and each
of them work with a different thing one
is it works with Radar materials another
is a chemist it has a lot of synthesis
work you have a virologist and you have
someone that does animal work if you if
you they're all separated in the picture
of the labs at the top and there's
consideration of going to an open lab
design but still maintaining the
proximity of these labs so the questions
that need to be answered asked are if
you are in an open lab design like this
how do you keep those different hazards
separated is it possible to do that and
second how does person somebody working
in lab a on the bottom know what's
someone working in lab C is working with
you and you have an open lab design like
this it's very important for people to
you know what their neighbors are
working with
much more important than it is when you
have actual physical walls that separate
the spaces those hazards are very easily
transmitted across through that lab
space and it's important to ask those
questions before the design gets
finalized in this kind of a concept so
we've talked about lab design the next
step is to make sure you have proper
engineering controls in place so what
are engineering controls well OSHA
defines them as a physical modification
to a process or process equipment or the
installation of further equipment with
the goal of preventing the release of
contaminants into the works place so
essentially these are going to be
physical modifications made to spaces or
equipment that help prevent exposures or
release of a hazardous substance so
let's talk about some engineering
controls so of the ones that are listed
here you have fume hoods biosafety
cabinets gas cabinets glove boxes sharps
and safe sharp devices machine guarding
eye washes safety showers are what types
of these are you currently using are
your existing controls aging out is
there new technology that makes your
devices new device newer devices better
or safer some of these things you should
consider is are you not using some of
these and you should be what changes do
you need to make to get the best and
safest lab you you can eye washes should
be plumbed to the sanitary sewer were
allowable you get more damage from a
water spill that spills on the floor
than the mining amount of chemical
that's diluted and goes down the drain
you have to make sure you check with
local building codes and wastewater
rules before implementing that type of
policy in design are the safety showers
accessible do they meet the ANSI
standard make sure you don't let them
install drench hoses and call them an
eye wash there those aren't sufficient
and complying with the ANSI standard
about eye washes and safety showers so
now that we've talked about engineering
controls let's move on to procedures
procedures or administrative controls
are put in place when elimination or
substitution our possible aren't
possible and engineering controls are
not sufficient to eliminate the hazard
so evaluating procedures is an important
part of designing a new lab or
renovating system spaces it's been my
experience that the procedures are
developed based on the existing lab
design or engineering or engineering
controls and there may be a better or
safer way to do the same procedure
technology evolves quickly and it's
important to not design for the past but
to design for the future so ask yourself
are your current procedures as safe as
they could be are there better processes
to achieve the same result and remember
do not replicate existing processes and
ways of doing things just because that's
how you've always done it so with
procedures considered we also need to
think about any PPE that may be required
for those procedures so you may be
thinking why would I need to think about
PPE when I'm designing a new lab the
answer is because sometimes the PPE has
special requirements like respirators
also PP currently in use may not be
necessary if engineering controls and
procedures change so some good questions
to ask when you're considering PPE are
shown in this slide
you know what PP is needed in lab are
there infrastructure needs an example I
show here is that for personal hair
purifying respirators in a bl3 lab you
may need some place to plug in the
batteries to recharge those batteries
you also may need showers so those are
pieces that are need to be incorporated
into that design are the engineering
controls that can be improved so you
don't need as much PPE and don't again
don't repeat the status quo just for the
sake of convenience or for historical
reasons redesign and and new lab design
as a chance to innovate and improve
things rather than to just maintain what
you have existing so finally
the people working in labs should be
considered and consulted when designing
renovating labs they know how things
work and may have a really good
suggestions on improving design and to
make operation safer and more efficient
you know makes you making sure the
people are trained appropriately and
make sure if you are a lab worker asked
to be involved in the design ask your
supervisor contribute your pains you're
going to be working in the space every
day going forward it's important that
they those stakeholders consider your
opinions too so just to review I want to
remind you to don't duplicate your
current lab now is your opportunity to
make it better rethink how you do your
procedures involve
all your stakeholders and then innovate
don't duplicate thank you for your
attention
thank you Matt I will now turn it over
to Brian Garrett thank you Judy thank
you Matt
so what we want to look at is not
discussed were the engineering control
specifically my experience of being on
manufacture side is on equipment and
engineering controls that are meant to
keep people safe and I'm going to look
at it specifically from the point of
view of biological safety cabinets I
mean that's that's my that's my
wheelhouse that's what I had most I'm
experienced in but there are also many
other ways there are other types of
equipment other processes that can be
looked at in the foyer even getting the
biosafety cabins all throughout a couple
of them vacuum networks are very
important there are a lot of people in
microbiology labs that do aspiration and
if you're looking at it that aspiration
a lot of people like to hook them up to
a network and the concern is if you
don't have the proper filters in place
you can cross contaminate that vacuum
network with multiple people's work so a
lot of times what we've seen best
practices is each cabinet or each
process would have its own aspiration
system that is portable it can be
cleaned it's be contaminated all in
furthermore it's not a shared network
that will mess up an entire floors worth
of work potentially so there are a lot
of other examples of working in
flexibility and improvements in design
but again I'm going to look at mostly
from the eyes of a biosafety cabinet so
why do we want to design for flexibility
there are a couple of different ways I'm
gonna look at this through a couple of
case studies we're really looking to see
or see equipment that can help with
flexibility to fix or replace what's
already happened so a lot of works are
the gun going into a design of a
building and maybe in some cases brick
and mortar already being laid we need to
and then they hit a snag something
happens we'll go over one of those
instances how we can fix that and then
for what's happening today we're you
know buildings are a lot longer life
span than most of the equipment that
goes into them so as buildings age and
technology changes we want to make sure
that that is backwards compatible
or that the building is forwards
compatible and we mostly again for what
will be needed tomorrow looking at what
your buildings current role or your lab
role is now is that always going to be
the same in five years 10 years 15 or
even 30 years
I'm sure you really wanted to design if
you can for the lab of tomorrow so first
we're going to look at using flex
flexibility to course-correct
and in this case study and we're looking
at there's a company that deals in
genetic markers and the compass Club DNA
gene attack there this facility was
specifically in Canada in Ottawa and
they called me completely other below
they've been working on a new lab and
they had questions pertaining to because
they wanted to put in several class to
type b2 biosafety cabinets I'm getting
to a lot of specifics here but those
types of cabinets are very well we're
very stringent and strict in their
exhaust requirements and to the point
where every cabinet means its own
independent exhaust system and I know
this drawing up here looks like a bunch
of spaghetti but what I was really drawn
to and looking at was you see here in
the below you seen two biosafety
cabinets I followed their ductwork
around okay everything's fine they're on
independent systems but those 200
systems go into a giant manhole and that
is an that doesn't no no when it comes
to lab design those two cadiz won't play
from me they don't run correctly they
might get them to run from maybe 5 to 10
months before they start going into a
lahrman failure mode so the work was
already being done the building was
already constructed these cabinets were
about ready to go in and the lab manager
called me and said I found out that you
know through talking with other people
that I can't do this design doesn't work
for my biological safety cabinets what
can I do
there's a new biosafety cabinet out
there called a c1 it was right right
there it was
registered and defined by NSF 49 called
the type C 1 and that cabin actually
allows you to do exactly what they've
done in their design and that is have
multiple cabinets hooked up to the same
mechanical system it also gave DNA gene
attack the ability to run those cabinets
with hazardous chemistry just like their
bees did so here's kind of a diagram of
what their room looked like what their
lab looked like they had four a2s in
there with a lab the lab bench in the
middle and I wanted to add two more what
they were able to do was change their
specifications from those in more beable
in mobile and inflexible b2 biosafety
cabinets and replace them with C ones
and in doing so they didn't have to
require a change order in their
engineering design this is really
important because when they went back
and told their architect that to keep
the b-2s they would need independent
exhaust systems their architect came
back with a number that was around like
three hundred thousand Canadian dollars
just to change the design that does not
include working water that does not
include ductwork installation or any
materials that was just a change in the
drawings that you saw in those first
couple slides so by providing them was
something that met their needs but was
much more flexible in allowing to keep
their own design they were able to save
a pretty big pretty big ticket when it
came to the cost of just opening and
moving into their laboratory space and I
believe here I have a picture of what
that lab looks like now see see the two
cabinets are closest to the camera here
are those see one you see their ductwork
up above
next case we're going to look at is
Creighton University so this is what's
going on for today's needs Creighton was
in a tough spot back in 2015 they were
they were challenged by the community of
Omaha Nebraska but also by their Board
of Regents to look at reducing energy
energy cost specifically so they started
this energy savings community it was
named person team and they were tasked
with finding projects on campus that
would haven't ROI of five years or less
or better and they'd already gone
through and found you know going to t5
lighting and more energy efficient
lighting
day lighting in some cases going to
geothermal pumps for heating they'd
found a lot of low-hanging fruit and
what was important was also that when it
came to their science buildings they
wanted to improve or boost this
environmental consciousness but the big
deal was they couldn't sacrifice safety
and they even had a safety person on
this committee so they did some research
they did something walking around and
they came across this type c1 biosafety
cabinet then I guess I should preface
this by saying there are safety the bio
safety person came around and said well
what if we replaced all the Derby twos
and the they saw that this was kind of a
winner from the start
each b2 biological safety cabinet I
talked about how stretch of exhaust
requirement they had on the previous
study on this one what they were looking
at you know that our ally and the safety
perspective each b2 and 15 years uses
about a hundred thousand dollars in air
cost alone so they're pretty significant
and they had at least 12 that were
coming up on 15 years of life so they
knew they were going to be replacing
these cabinets anyway and they wanted to
know if they could replace these beaches
with sea ones and what they were able to
find was that they could actually
replace them and run them run those sea
ones in a recirculating a mode so they
didn't even need the
chemical protective nature of the b2 to
begin with that was just wasted air and
therefore wasted money so here is a some
more fuzzy age of one of the
recirculating type c1 cabinets at
Creighton University and again what was
important about this they saw that
replacing the b2 s are disconnecting
this cabinet was a winner idea from the
beginning when they actually ran their
calculations on their first 12 cabinets
they showed a two-point six-year ROI and
that they were going to realize an
annual savings of over fifty thousand
dollars what they were really captivated
with was the fact that this new type of
cabinet is flexible it saved money but
it actually maintained and increased
safety within the laboratory space so
for them it was a win-win-win that
really propelled the university from
from being a safety oriented to a
environmental conscientious University
you
the purifier axiom class - biosafety
cabinets 3-piece work surface looks
different than any other class - BSC the
Kim's own aptly named for its ability to
handle microbiological applications
involving chemistry is a direct exhaust
workcenter personal protective air
flowing into the cabinet and down flow
air flowing over the side surfaces of
the interior coloured blue are
recirculated through the cabinets supply
air system chemical vapors should not be
introduced in these airflow areas
err and the column above the Kim's own
coloured red is exhausted from the
cabinet in a single pass
when the axiom is in its recirculating a
mode this exhaust air is simply returned
to the lab through the exhaust interface
when inducted b-mode chemically
contaminated exhaust air is safely
removed from the laboratory
a type a BSc is not designed to handle
hazardous chemistry type of b2b SCS can
but exhaust massive volumes of expensive
room air in the process the axiom must
closely resembles the type B one
internal airflow however to work safely
in a b-1 the operator must be trained
and worked behind an invisible moving
line known as the smoke split the axiom
type c1 is the only cabinet that reduces
energy consumption while containing
chemicals and is safer and easier to use
because it does not use a smoke split
so the video illustrated what were what
the cabinet's design was for obviously
as a biological safety cabinet is safety
this cabinet was specifically designed
and was accepted for applications that
were using both bot hazards biology in
hazardous chemistry but to serve the
needs of scientists in the future and
with their flexible lab design and safe
lab design we wanted to make sure that
the cabinet was capable of being
flexible with that building installation
so speaking of the flexibility and
having an eye to the future look look at
there our last case study here which is
looking at flexibility from the ground
up and I'm actually going to use to
illustrate the purpose of this equipment
in this thought process I was actually a
building and Matt has jurisdiction over
and that's the University of
nebraska-lincoln veterinary diagnostic
center so this newly constructed
building houses several laboratories and
I believe they just moved in in the
middle of last month but it's also so
under the jurisdiction in university
Brassica Lincoln it's also the state of
Nebraska is reference laboratory for
right and for veterinary diagnostic
medicine so you know a bunch of cows go
down ill or you know maybe there's there
some an outbreak of avian virus or
whatever all of those specimens will be
sent to this laboratory for diagnosis
and then Jordan state Nebraska or if
you've got elevated at that point CDC
USDA for for treatment purposes when
they were designing and Witney this
building and this is where Matt's
experience and expertise comes into play
they wanted to work at having a building
that would meet the need that they have
right now but also would be
energy-efficient would be safety which
is obviously a big thing but also the
building would last for them into
20 30 40 years so sure you so need some
screenshots of some documents that I
received here you can see a bit of the
equipment list that was sent out for bid
you'll see that from the very beginning
that they had already designed or
started specifying and designing the
building around a flexible biosafety
cabinet fume hood configuration so they
had cabinets there were the a2 type the
type C type they had fume hood and
laminar flow cabinets so they had
already started working at what would
their engineering controls need to be
now but the inclusion of that type see
shows that they were thinking that this
may need to change in the future we need
to be ready to go if if the mission of
this facility changes down the line so
here's some symbols and the reasons are
important is I'm going to show you a
couple of floor plan to several of their
laboratories and how they used and
thought about this from a process
standpoint so here's the the histology
lab and this is going to be pretty much
a straightforward processing tissue
culture lab door just like I said
histology lab and they built it knowing
that they're going to need an area for
for preparation of work you have a
single fume hood off in the corner and
then here you also have the highest
density of these flexible cabinets but
you've seen three ducted biosafety
cabinets here in labs are right next to
each other so from here on the Stark
they knew that they were going to begin
with processes that could be using
benzene formaldehyde xylene higher
levels of chemistry than you would
normally find in a biological and
microbiological laboratory so they knew
they were going to start with those
cabinets ducted and that's where these
types these went and this is an image of
one of their cabinets installed next to
some specimen storage spacing and then
you have the virology serology in
bacteriology laboratories so these are
pretty much cookie cutter labs you can
see that you've got quite a bit of floor
space here the blue boxes again these
are the type a biosafety cabinet so this
is typically the workhorse of your
microbiological laboratory it's it's no
surprise that they're going to be a high
concentration of those wherever you're
going to have pathogens being worked on
and typically those are not going to be
ducted areas or ducted biosafety
cabinets but you got you have to have a
lot of them to process especially in a
processing laboratory but also on this
floor or on this lab you have this
number of fume hood these would be
ducted and then you also have a see one
in the corner on one of the other
laboratories so here's where that the
ability to modulate or design
flexibility comes into play because it's
now you can imagine that that red
cabinet were a b2 or some other
inflexible design this laboratory with
those hoods so far apart would need
several different duct runs that means
several different blowers and when you
try and run that it increases the price
tag of the laboratory quite
substantially furthermore with those
bees they have to run in a ducted mode
so at this cabinet or this labs need
ever changes they can disconnect any of
those c1 cabinets and they basically
become blue cabinets and you do that you
end up saving $50,000 over the life of
the cabinet and that's per unit and this
is just an image of that laboratory and
you can see down the row on the
right-hand side multiple a2s are stacked
back on each other I'm just showing that
these are I believe six foot units so
the biggest and most workspace you're
going to get this is completely
protected for any hazardous biology work
we wanted to talk about adoption of
flexibility adoption of good lab
practices when you're going into design
specifically from the biological stands
in the biosafety cabinet standpoint how
can that adoption flexibility help the
lab at the case of a c1 you can lower
upfront costs and it does that by
reducing costly over designing or
purchasing of new equipment due to
operational changes if you buy a b2 and
then all of a sudden you no longer need
chemical protection that cabinets only
going to run that level so you're
wasting tons of money on the back end
but then also if you want to save money
you're going to buy all new types of
cabinets flexibility in that design
point really reduces your total cost
from an upfront standpoint as well which
you can also look at again going back to
the example used at the beginning
looking at vacuum networks your safety
officers say Matt walks into your
laboratory he sees that a guy using in
coli and Salmonella in one lab has
hooked up to a vacuum network that has
doing sterile tissue culturing the other
and they're hooked up to another lab
that also is working with regenerative
medicine lines and then all of a sudden
the guy using regenerative medicine
lines gets cross-contamination in all of
his is costly cell cultures are dying
he's going to tell them we'll rip out
this network or stop using that Network
and now we're going to have to install
separate aspiration systems all the way
across you've now paid for a very
expensive vacuum network that's now
completely useless so the same kind of a
thought process going there you know
avoid costly changes especially during
construction and innovation
due to poor communication and flexible
designs one of the things Matt talked
about where people making sure that the
design phase has the right people on
board and everyone is consulted can do a
lot to to mitigate engineering change
orders which as I expressed like with
Dean at Unitec 11 costing $300,000
Canadian there was another customer that
we have worked with in New York similar
thing they were
either redesigning for 6b Tunes or
incorporating the c1 when they went to
their engineer it was a million and a
half dollars that they were gonna have
to do again just for drawings this is
just for those architects expertise and
changing doctor work on paper not even
getting into the actual implementation
phase so those adopting that flexibility
are being able to accept and see change
down the road can go a long way in
reducing the money that's going to take
me to your lab up and running and then
ultimately I mean everyone likes to
lower lifetime operational costs it's
really hard for a laboratory more
allowed manager or laboratory people in
some cases to see 15 years down the road
but when you look at or you go to the
finance people and you can tell them
that we hey we can save if we do this we
can save half a million dollars over 15
years or a million and a half dollars
over 15 years by adapting and adopting
new technology into the laboratory or
into the process in my experience ears
perk up at that point then we can do
that by going to efficiency design
modular design really want to harmonize
what's going on sometimes it's just a
different blend of what's used in the
past to make the laboratory not just
more efficient but also safer Norway
that leads to an increase in efficiency
and what's great about efficiency is in
today's world companies are in companies
laboratories or all the things are
asking the same amount of people to do
more work and the only way that will
happen is by increasing the
functionality and output of the
laboratory and the people that use that
laboratory
so the gone are the days of rigid
construction that that requires
Anchorage to to hard lines and hard
facilities laboratories are becoming
much more fluid in their design as a
result of the fluidity of what they're
tasked with doing
so we ask what does the lab of tomorrow
look like for you
the last couple of slides which I
believe you'll have access to are going
to have several different resources that
will help guide you or your design team
through the process of giving your lab
up and running so I welcome you to take
a look at those and I believe that is
the end of this presentation
thank you Matt Bryan for your
informative presentations it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask Matt Anderson and/or Bryan Garrett
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is
Matt how did your design team or Javed
your team finding architect and lab
planning firms with lab design
experience
um I think predominantly we've looked at
other other institutions and what when
they have built new facilities and found
out what teams they have used I know
there's specifically with the vet
Diagnostic Center that Brian talked
about we did find the Diagnostic Center
staff went and visited a few other
diagnostic centers and to get some ideas
and then did researched architects and
firms design firms that had had
experience with those buildings both
spoke a lot about engineering controls
hoods and biosafety cabinets have you
come across or are there other examples
of places where flexibility should be
considered and that would you want to
address it first um there can be one of
the examples would be as Brian did point
out what the the aspiration systems that
that n vacuum systems those are some of
the things that can be thought about
when you're designing things whether you
want to have that centralized or if it's
going to be specific to each lab and I
isolated that can provide some
flexibility another way to provide some
flexibility that we actually did
implement in the Diagnostic Center was
to put a lot of the utilities and things
up above so they were drop-down so the
the room could be rearranged and some of
the furniture was more mobile and so the
room could be reconfigured in the future
if the needs change for the space yeah
absolutely so something else we'll
looking at we talked about predominately
about biological safety cabinets but
also look at water systems water purity
oftentimes for a small-scale lab can be
pointed use and can actually be costly
from a cost perspective but also from a
quality perspective or negative from the
quality
but if you have a large single source
point of water that's central to a large
facility by the time that water gets to
your to the end of the line it may not
be the type 1 water you need your high
grade chemistry or HPLC and that kind of
work so in some cases the building is
going to have water purification systems
but for certain instances certain uses
pointed use laboratory water can be
required or necessary along with that
glassware washers some places like ANOVA
Varian's they get along just fine with
having one large giant rack washing
system that works great if you have one
chemist though that begins doing high
grade chemistry need a high degree of
control over the purity of the water and
the glassware that comes out of that he
may need a separate system so the
foursome into a central a large grade
washer for an entire floor would not be
feasible those are just two more
examples fume hoods mixing ducted fume
hoods with Douglas fume hoods can can
also limit energy consumption limit the
amount of money spent per year on that
valuable air that we talked about kind
of with biosafety cabinets so again
those all of those designs and any part
of the process that can differ from
laboratory space to laboratory space or
researcher researchers should be looked
at very specifically to determine what's
best from that laboratory going forward
that discussed a collaborative design
approach how soon in a project should
various disciplines be approached about
their needs Brian would you want to talk
about that one first or um make it work
okay sure I would say as soon as
possible I mean you can start talking
about some of these things and in the
early stages where you're just you know
doing some brainstorming on planning
there may be a chance for those that may
be the earliest chance for the the lab
workers to be involved in the discussion
to talk about the procedures they're
doing and things new technology they may
see that they want to incorporate but
yeah I would say as soon as
possible get ever get people involved
and that this next one's for you how do
you raise funds to start off a
small-scale laboratory that's something
that we could do you think talk about
this in this frame here well I guess the
I'm not sure what small-scale means I
mean if you're maybe and they could the
person could be more specific would you
like that yeah
hi Matt I've been looking for some
references for PPE requirements
recommended for different categories and
types of labs can you recommend any
resources there's lots of resources out
there if you're looking at bio
biological labs I would recommend the
bio safety in biomedical micro
biological & biomedical laboratories
manual that's a book that's put out by
CDC and NIH and it's you can access it
on CDC's website there's also prudent
practices in the laboratory is a book
that's put out as well and reference
document there are a lot of academic
institutions that provide their guidance
free on their websites so that's another
resource that that I would suggest
taking advantage of hey great and while
we're waiting for additional questions
to come in I would like to once again
thank Matt Anderson and Brian Garrett
for their presentations if you have any
final comments maybe Brian first sure
and all the projects new laboratory
leaders whether to redesign a reformat
or new construction what I've often
found is that the more questions that
can be answered and in specifics about
the research being done the number of
researchers you want to house how big do
you want to get in is sustainable for
your institution more of those questions
that can be flushed out
before you even get to talking to
architects engineers lab planners the
more streamline the whole process is
going to be so not disgusting and making
sure you build the right team and you
look at things from a systemic and
process point of view all of those
questions are going to make or those
answers having that data is going to
make the job for your architect me a
design team a lot easier and also from a
practical standpoint the less they have
to change down the road the less the
more likely you are to stay on budget
and for your building to be completed on
time so I think that's those are all
great things and I know with with Matt's
experience he's looking for those real
world tips having that stuff up front
makes makes everything a lot easier
lots to hear yeah I just I think one
thing I wanted to share is just to make
sure that once you are involvement
project to Stratos stay involved because
sometimes once you're beyond the design
phase and the design has been settled
and construction starts you tend to back
off a little bit sometimes but sometimes
there's things that come up through
construction through meetings that that
need to be decided um more or less on on
the spot and it's important to make sure
that you're still involved in that
process
um kempert can provide that input when
it's requested from the design firm or
from the construction personnel so
that's all okay thank you both once
again I would also like to thank our
sponsor lab không có for making today's
educational webcast possible this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CTE button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through March 26 2018 you'll receive an
email from laberd's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay we share that announcement with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon
by